Ось так на дні Балтійського моря у першій половині вересня завершилося будівництво "Північного потоку-2".
Тепер справа за сертифікацією газогону, яка може тривати декілька місяців.
Щоб прискорити цей процес, Москва, за словами оглядачів, сприяє зростанню цін на газ у Європі
та домовляється про транспортування російського газу в обхід України.
Цього тижня у Будапешті уклали довгострокову угоду про постачання "Газпромом" газу в Угорщину
із щорічним обсягом 4 з половиною мільярди кубів блакитного палива.
Контракт розраховано на 15 років, і він почне діяти вже від 1 жовтня.
Це означає, що російський газ буде постачатися в Угорщину в обхід України.
Київ жорстко відреагував на такі дії Будапешта, заявивши, що це виключно політичне, економічно необґрунтоване рішення,
прийняте на догоду Кремлю та на шкоду національним інтересам України й українсько-угорським відносинам,
бо не відповідає принципам Договору про основи добросусідства та співробітництва між країнами.
Угорщина теж різко відреагувала і навіть назвала спроби України перешкодити цій угоді рівносильними порушенню суверенітету Угорщини.
Я маю відкидати кожну спробу втручання.
Енергетична безпека Угорщини не є питанням компромісу.
Ми повинні забезпечити опалення в будинках угорців взимку. Це наше завдання.
При цьому Угорщині вигідніше отримувати газ транзитом через розгалужену газотранспортну систему України,
яка дозволяє найкоротшим шляхом безперебійно постачати газ до країн Європи.
Як видно на графіці, шлях транзитного газу в Угорщину через Україну набагато коротший,
ніж новим "Турецьким потоком" - а це 930 км через Чорне море
до турецького берега, а потім Балканами через Болгарію і Сербію.
Для України контракт "Газпрому" з Угорщиною - це саме те, чого в Києві побоювалися давно.
Нові шляхи газового транзиту з Росії до Європи обходять Україну з півночі і з півдня.
При цьому формально причепитися Євросоюзу і США нема до чого.
У випадку з Угорщиною "Газпром" використовує "Турецький потік".
А щодо нього ані Анґела Меркель, ані Джо Байден жодних обіцянок Україні не давали.
Експерти сприймають цей угорсько-російський контракт як чіткий сигнал,
що після 2024 го року "Газпром" будуватиме свої транзитні відносини в обхід України.
Ось цей крок, пов'язаний з новим договором з Угорщиною, є першим кроком, спрямованим на те, щоб фізично скоротити транзит через Україну.
Наступний крок буде у випадку запуску в експлуатацію "Північного потоку-2".
Тоді через газотранспортну систему України залишиться якийсь мінімальний обсяг транзиту,
який фізично недостатній для того, щоб зберегти маршрут функціональним. Просто фізика.
І тоді російська сторона урочисто оголосить про те, що Україна не виконує своїх зобов’язань щодо транзиту,
не може забезпечити транспортування газу в Європу і немає сенсу далі виконувати цю угоду і розриває її.
Звичайно, будуть судові позови і так далі. Але сам факт того, що Росія цей сценарій зараз відпрацьовує з допомогою Угорщини - він достатньо показовий.
Газовий конфлікт з Угорщиною продовжує набирати обертів.
Україна вирішила звернутися до Єврокомісії, щоб та оцінила відповідність
нової угорсько-російської газової угоди європейському законодавству в сфері енергетики.
Усе це відбувається на фоні рекордного зростання цін на газ у Європі.
Зазвичай європейські підземні газосховища до зими заповнюються практично повністю.
Але в цьому сезоні обсяги накопиченого там газу становлять лише трохи більше половини від норми.
Показово, що найгірші справи із запасами блакитного палива в Європі саме у "Газпрому".
Ідеться перш за все про газосховище в Редені.
Це не тільки найбільше ПГС у Німеччині, але й в цілому в ЄС.
Так ось там рівень запасів лише 5 відсотків. Це небувалий стан.
Рік тому, за офіційними даними німецького об'єднання операторів підземних сховищ, рівень заповнення становив 87 відсотків.
У разі повторення торішніх затяжних холодів ситуація може стати загрозливою.
Як так сталося, що Європа й особливо Німеччина зустрічають зиму недостатньо підготовленими?
Це здивувало всіх, ніхто такого не очікував.
Але ми всі недооцінили, що в нас склалася ситуація, коли пропозиція доволі убога, а попит дуже високий.
А обсяги газу з Росії, які раніше компенсували це, цього року набагато менші, ніж два роки тому за звичайної ситуації.
При цьому експерти наголошують, що "Газпром" неможливо звинуватити у невиконанні контрактних зобов'язань.
Поставки велися безперебійно, але саме з пов'язаних із "Газпромом" європейських підземних сховищ,
які напередодні зими спорожніли і більше не поповнюються.
У зв'язку з цим виникає сильна підозра, що це зроблено спеціально для того,
щоб натиснути на європейців, на регуляторів у Німеччині та ЄС, щоб вони якомога швидше,
причому без будь-яких умов, без врахування Третього енергопакету ЄС дали дозвіл на експлуатацію відразу двох ниток "Північного потоку-2".
Низький рівень заповнення газпромівських газосховищ багато в чому виглядає як шантаж з метою протиснути початок експлуатації "Північного потоку-2".
"Північний потік-2" фактично вже добудований, але суперечки навколо проєкту не вщухають.
Опоненти вважають, що економічної необхідності в ньому немає,
але при цьому виникають додаткові геополітичні ризики.
Адже йдеться не про те, щоб не імпортувати газ з Росії.
Ідеться про імпорт газу з Росії без залучення наших східноєвропейських партнерів, окей?
Я дуже хочу наголосити на цій різниці. Тому що ми вважаємо, що з геополітичної точки зору
це неправильний вибір - іти по головах наших східноєвропейських партнерів, і перш за все України.
Однак пересічних європейців у найближчі місяці будуть хвилювати швидше
не питання геополітики, а тепло в їхніх будинках і ціни на енергоносії.